[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Thanks,
everyone, for joining us
for this Talks at Google event.
We have two fantastic
authors here
for you today, Cory
Doctorow and John Scalzi.
So we're graced
with their presence.
[APPLAUSE]
Cory Doctorow,
author of "Walkaway,"
so Cory is a science fiction
author, activist, journalist,
and blogger.
He's the co-editor of Boing
Boing, that's boingboing.net,
and the author of the
best-selling "Little Brother,"
which is actually just
recently optioned by Paramount,
so it's going to be a movie,
with Don Murphy producing--
pretty cool stuff.
He's also the former European
director of the Electronic
Frontier Foundation.
And he co-founded the
UK Open Rights Group.
He was born in Toronto, Canada
and now lives in Burbank.
[CHEER]
That's for Toronto or for Bur--?
That's for Toronto.
[LAUGHTER]
CORY DOCTOROW:
That's for Toronto.
SPEAKER: No Burbank love.
OK, and then we have
John Scalzi, author
of "The Collapsing Empire."
He's one of the most
popular and acclaimed SF
to emerge in the last decade.
His massively successful
debut, "Old Man's
War--" SF as in science
fiction, not San Francisco--
his massively successful
debut, "Old Man's War"
won him the Science
Fiction's John W. Campbell
Award for Best New Writer.
His "New York
Times" best sellers
include "The Last
Colony," "Fuzzy Nation,"
and "Red Shirts," which
won 2013's Hugo Award
for Best Novel and "Lock In."
Material from his
widely read blog,
"Whatever" has also earned
him two other Hugo Awards.
He lives in Ohio with
his wife and daughter.
And let's put our hands together
for them to welcome them.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHN SCALZI: Hello, Cory.
CORY DOCTOROW: Hello, John.
It's nice to see you again.
JOHN SCALZI: I know, it's been
so long since I've seen you.
CORY DOCTOROW: It has.
So John is at the
very end of his tour,
and I'm at the
very start of mine.
John has come from
my future to warn me
about the terrible catastrophes
in the coming week.
JOHN SCALZI: Right, it's
hydrate and hand sanitizer--
these are the two things that
will get you through most
of these particular events.
CORY DOCTOROW: Well,
hydration will get you
through times of
no hand sanitizer
better than hand
sanitizer would get you
through times of no hydration.
JOHN SCALZI: There's so much
truth in that statement.
I can't--
CORY DOCTOROW: There really is.
JOHN SCALZI: I don't
even know where to start.
CORY DOCTOROW: I
didn't even realize it
till I was halfway through
that it's actually true.
JOHN SCALZI: It
is actually true.
You were trying to be
arch, and yet you've
actually spoken a home truth.
That is really useful to
people who are on the--
CORY DOCTOROW: Don't
drink hand sanitizer.
JOHN SCALZI: Don't
I mean, no matter
how fruity it smells,
it's just going to end in pain.
CORY DOCTOROW: That's right.
JOHN SCALZI: But you do--
I mean, you do see
a lot of people,
and you shake a lot of hands.
And the very first time
that I ever went on tour,
I shook somebody's
hand in San Diego.
And the next thing I knew, I
was in Minneapolis and Phoenix
was somewhere in between that.
And it's like, I
can't do that again.
I don't know what
I did in Phoenix,
but I can't ever go
back to that city now.
CORY DOCTOROW: So John,
you wrote this book,
"The Collapsing Empire."
JOHN SCALZI: Yes, I did.
CORY DOCTOROW: A kind
of eco-catastrophe
that you didn't realize
was an eco-catastrophe
until the reviews
started coming in.
JOHN SCALZI: Yeah,
what happened was,
this is the classic idea
of the author so fixated
on their own specific idea that
they don't really think about,
necessarily, about the obvious
wider implications that
are clear to everyone else.
In my specific case, when I
was writing "The Collapsing
Empire," I was thinking
about the age of sail
and the age of empires,
basically between the 15th
through 18th
centuries in Europe.
And what I was
thinking about, what
would happen to all
those empires in Europe--
Portugal, the UK, Spain--
if all of a sudden, the jet
stream and the ocean currents
just suddenly went away,
or shifted so significantly
that all the things
that they took for
granted about how they were
going to get around the world
to get to the New World
or to get to Japan,
just suddenly disappeared.
And this is relevant to
me because I created--
because I strongly believe
that the speed of light
is not only a good idea,
but actually the law,
and that you wouldn't want to
go close to the speed of light
anyway, because anytime
you hit something,
space is only mostly empty.
So that when you hit
something, of course, boom,
that all turns into
energy, and you're doomed.
So I created this thing
called the "flow," which
is a sort of
extra-dimensional conduit
that gets you from one place
to another, because it doesn't
have to obey the rules of
this particular universe,
because it sort of
sits on top of it.
It's basically a cheat, but
a very interesting cheat.
But it works like
ocean currents,
or it works like the jet stream.
And it's a feature
of the universe
that we have no control over.
And so they built this
entire empire using the flow,
just assuming that
the flow is always
going to be there, because
as far as they know,
it always has been.
But the universe doesn't care
what you think about permanence
or what you need.
It's basically just going
to do what it's going to do.
And eventually the
flow goes away.
So I'm busy thinking
about these parallels
to ocean currents and the flow.
And people are coming up
to me at these events,
and they're going, "It's
about oil, isn't it?"
And I'm, like, I guess it is,
because it's the thing that
happens where you have--
you write something, and
you put it out in the world.
And it's no longer just
exclusively in your brain.
It is now in
dialogue with what's
in the brain of somebody else.
So the person who's
looking at it is going,
this is obviously about oil.
This is obviously
about climate change.
about such and such.
Sometimes they can get
really wacky about it.
But other times, it's like, yep.
Because I also live in the now.
And I do actually think
about oil and climate change.
And even if I'm not thinking
about them directly,
obviously, that sort of stuff
is going to seep into what I do.
CORY DOCTOROW: I also wonder
if there isn't a parallel
to be drawn, though, with some
sort of theory-free knowledge.
The thing that brings all
these people into catastrophe
is that they don't really
know how the flow works.
But it's worked so
well for so long
that they assume
it'll be stable.
And we have a lot
of things that we
do that are kind of folk
ways rather than reality.
We'll A/B split our way
into some optimal pattern,
that we don't really
know why it works.
But it's stable for a long
time, and so we build up
big edifices on it.
And then all of a sudden,
it changes or turns out
that it's fragile.
JOHN SCALZI: What happens
is, like an example,
science fiction fandom--
there's this saying
that if you do something
once it's a tradition,
if you do it twice,
It's a hallowed tradition.
And what that means is
that people get so used
to doing things
heuristically, they
don't even question whether
that process makes sense outside
of that specific thing.
And we do.
As humans, we do things
so heuristically.
It's like, why do you do this?
Because it's always worked.
Why do you do it this way?
Because when I did it the other
way, it didn't work the way
I wanted it to, so I'm
always going to do this.
Can you explain why this
works the way it does?
It just works the way it does.
Stop asking me these questions.
I have things to do.
We do things so heuristically
that what we end up doing is,
we become trapped to a
process without understanding
how the process works.
And that's of course,
how we fall down.
Now, let's segue a little
bit into "Walkaway."
CORY DOCTOROW: Sure.
JOHN SCALZI: And we're talking
about one of the things
that you do in "Walkaway"
is that you actually
posit that a lot of
people are actually
going to cooperate in trying
times, rather than go,
oh, no, it's every
person for themselves.
And let's get at it.
Now there are some people
who would say, heuristically,
that when you go
and have a crisis,
the thing that you
should do is just
sort of look out for
yourself and assume
everybody else is going to
take care of themselves.
Do you--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CORY DOCTOROW: Yeah, so I mean,
the theory that 99.9% of people
are total bastards has a really
significant statistical problem
with it, which is
that the people who
evince this theory
almost always also say,
"but not you, me, and
all the people we know."
So the likelihood, in a
world where 99.9% of people
are total bastards, that
everyone that you know
isn't is really low.
It's much more likely that
the people that you know
are a representative selection
of the people around them,
and that they have
the dual nature
of all fragile and
imperfect humans, which
is to say that on a good day,
they rise to the occasion.
And on a bad day, they
do things that haunt them
forever as their regrets.
And what really matters
in terms of society
is not how it works
when it's working well,
but what lessons it teaches
us that come to mind
easily when things go wrong.
The liquidation preference
for a civilization
that's based on every
person for themselves,
my gain is your loss,
let's all be rational,
self-interested actors, and
through that will emerge
some kind of competitive
but optimized world,
is that when things go
wrong, you see your neighbors
as your competitors and not
as your potential saviors,
or people with whom you have
some kind of mutual destiny
or mutual responsibility to.
And all of these
stories that we have
through our history, of
civilizations falling in ways
large and small, whether that's
just the lights going out
because the power
plant collapsed,
or because we had
a horrible quake,
or whatever, or all the way
up to the fall of the empire,
every one of those
situations was not
resolved by the people
who ran to the hills.
By definition, when
you run to the hills,
you do not solve those problems.
It's all solved by the
people who run to the middle
to see how they can help.
And coordinating
that help is hard.
And I always feel
like there's a lot
of drama latent in
the story of people
who agree with each other
on what should be done,
but disagree about
how it should be done,
and that it's actually a
much more compelling drama
in the end then the easy drama
of people who actually disagree
about what should be done.
The man versus man story
is a lot less interesting
than, we're all on the
same side but I hate you
and I want to kill
you story, which
is something that is
much harder to resolve,
as anyone who's ever
gone to Christmas dinner
with their family can tell you.
And so "Walkaway" is
a story about people
who are consciously
trying to form
societies that fail gracefully,
instead of societies
that work well.
And that they're trying to use
the coordinative, latent power
of technology to get there.
Rather than thinking
about technology
as the thing that helps us
manufacture or communicate,
they're thinking about
it as a thing that
lets us add our labor
one to the other,
even if we don't all agree
on what's to be done.
And if it turns out that I
throw some code or some work
into a project that turns
out to be superfluous to it,
that's OK.
We can just leave
it by the wayside,
or factor it out in
future revisions.
Rather than having someone
sit down and tell us
all what to do, we all do what
we think needs to be done.
And we have a tool that
lets the parts of it that
are useful glom together.
So today, we can build
an encyclopedia the way
that we used to
apply bureaucracy
to the problem of
building a bake sale.
And tomorrow, maybe we
could build skyscrapers
and space programs that
way, without the kind
of coercive
hierarchical control.
Maybe we can use
additive labor to do it.
I see you shaking your head.
Perhaps you should
read the book.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] build
a Wikipedia skyscraper.
CORY DOCTOROW: But
I think there were
a lot of people who said
they didn't want a Wikipedia
encyclopedia for about 10 years.
And there were a
lot of people who
said that they didn't
want a GNU operating
system for about 10 years.
And they were really right
for the first 10 years.
That's the amazing thing.
It's as Jimmy Wales says, "It is
a complete disaster in theory.
It only works in practice."
JOHN SCALZI: Here's a question.
And one of the things
that you can say
is, all right, so the
idea that cooperation
is kind of a wonderful
thing not to be disputed,
but how do you keep
a wonderful thing,
a wonderful communal
thing, from basically
being swamped by the bastards?
CORY DOCTOROW: Well,
and that's a problem
that the people in this
story really contend with.
We have a new move
in the 21st century
for resolving disputes,
which is forking.
I mean, it's not entirely new.
It's just lower cost
than it's ever been.
There's this thing
in Canada where
the further west you go,
the weirder the Mennonites
get, because Mennonitism
is a schematic faith,
because it has this article
that you shouldn't be worldly.
But worldly is not a
crisply defined idea.
And so what's one
person's worldliness
is someone else's
non-worldliness.
I have a friend who grew up
in a Mennonite community that
was founded by people who
disagreed about whether or not
vertical blinds were cool.
They thought they were.
The people who are old order
thought they shouldn't be.
And so they moved west.
So you get all the way
west to Saskatchewan,
and there's that wonderful
science fiction writer named
Karl Schroeder, who is a second,
multigenerational Mennonite.
His father was a
Mennonite TV repairman.
And so this was like somehow
reconcilable with this faith.
So that's a very expensive
way of schisming,
but we have a much cheaper
way of schisming now,
which is that we
can fork the code.
We can keep the code
bases reconciled,
but we can add
stuff on top of it.
And so the kind of Debian
into Ubuntu model of schisming
is a much more interesting
one, because it
allows for a lot of
experimentation at the margin.
You can do a lot of parallel
universe stuff, where
it's like, what if
we reran Debian,
but we gave up on
this principle,
or we included some
non-free repositories,
or we did something else
that was key core to Debian.
And then you get to
find out how's it work?
Instead of having a kind
of abstract argument,
you can actually try it,
and see what happens.
JOHN SCALZI: So it's like a
choose-your-own adventure.
CORY DOCTOROW: Or like
multiple parallel universes,
and so the walkways, for
better and for worse--
the thing about
walkaway, it's a sort
of Burning Man-ish subculture.
But what it is, is they
walk away from the world.
They find brownfield
sites that have
been left behind by the collapse
of industrial civilization.
They harvest the
waste stream that's
exhausted off what's left of
post-industrial civilization.
And using cool tools,
they build fully
automated leisure communism.
And if someone comes along
and says, that patch of dirt
is mine, and that
garbage that you're using
doesn't belong to you,
rather than argue about it,
they just go somewhere else.
Because all garbage and patches
of blighted land are fungible.
And so they just go
find somewhere else
to try out their experiment.
And they're able to do this
for better or for worse.
And the worse is
that there are times
when doing that actually
does cost them something.
And they can't
always reconcile it.
And then the people
who have kicked them
off plot of land A
sometimes aren't happy
with them walking
to plot of land
B. Sometimes they're mortally
offended that they've
walked off.
And in particular, when the
walkaways who are walking away
are scientists who've taken the
practical cure for death out
of the default world, and kind
of stolen fire from the gods,
and brought it to everyone
else, in a kind of Aaron Swartz
Sci-Hub kind of exfiltration
of the technology
necessary for immortality,
the super-rich
realize that they're
going to have
to spend the rest
of eternity with us,
and become really,
really upset about it.
And walking away ceases
to be a viable strategy.
Now they have to
start running away.
JOHN SCALZI: I like
watching you talk.
Because the funny thing
about Cory is, you're like,
Cory, here's a thought.
And he goes, so, thwoomp.
And it comes out, 10,000 ideas
in this stream of-- like you're
the firehose of ideas.
CORY DOCTOROW: Oh,
that's kind of you.
JOHN SCALZI: But
it's true though.
And so when we were first
talking, and they were, like,
we want to pair
you up with Cory.
I'm, like, yeah, sign me up.
I am the carbon fuel or the
carbon rod to his nuclear fuel.
Because he's going to
go all over the place,
and I'm going to be, OK.
Here we go.
CORY DOCTOROW: I
love this analogy.
I love that you're
the inert carbon rod.
JOHN SCALZI: But,
actually, here's
the thing that we had talked
about in previous things.
And I'm going to approach
it to you a little bit.
One of the things that
we were talking about
is one of the issues
of way back when,
with primogeniture, and how
that related to colonialism.
Primogeniture means
only one person,
usually the son, inherits.
And then colonialism to an
extent solved that problem,
because you could go from--
you could take those second
and third sons or whatever,
and have them find their own
fortunes out in the world.
And eventually, it
exhausts itself,
because there's only so
much world out there.
And that leads to
a kind of collapse
that caused, for example,
World War I and then
as a consequence, World War II.
But let me apply that to
the world of the walkaways.
One of the posits here
is that when you fork,
you can just go somewhere else.
Sooner or later, you'll
run out of somewhere else.
CORY DOCTOROW: Yes,
so in that regard--
so to kind of reiterate this
earlier part, Thomas Piketty,
in "Capital of
the 21st Century,"
he hypothesizes that
the age of colonialism
allowed every family to create
as many dynastic fortunes
as they had sons, and
that eventually, you
run out of colonies that you can
get dynastic fortunes out of.
But the dynastic fortunes had
a character of rivalrousness.
The fortune that I have is
a fortune you can't have.
What the walkways get is like
a kind of federated universe
of slightly different
variations on their ethics,
and on their design aesthetics,
and on their practices,
their engineering practices,
their social practices.
And so you're right,
there may be some element
that is optimal for you
that isn't perfectly suited
in any of the places.
But they're also not
super intensely specified.
So the likelihood
that there's something
that's really important to
you that no one will tolerate,
and you can't find
anywhere to do it,
that's a pretty low likelihood.
And this coordination, it's
a really remarkable thing.
In fact, one of the
impetuses for this book
was, I think Google did.
You guys built a data
center in Belgium
in a valley where
two-thirds of the time, you
don't need chillers.
The ambient temperature
is low enough
that you don't need chillers.
And the rest of the time, they
just shut off the servers,
because the file
system is distributed,
and you can
coordinate the labor.
And this was a remarkable
realization for me,
that we could use coordination
to simply shunt around
resources to wherever
they're least environmentally
catastrophic, wherever they're
kind of most harmonious
with the rest of the world.
And we could realize
these new efficiencies
that really challenge
the notion that you
can't have infinite
growth in a finite world.
Infinite growth implies that you
don't have any kind of process
automation, and you don't have
any changes in what people
want, and that will
just keep growing.
We'll keep making cars that
have x tons of steel in them,
and we can do that infinitely.
That's obviously not true.
But there doesn't seem
to be any bottom in sight
as to how few tons of
steel you can put in a car.
And so in that regard, we can
get some extremely flexible
growth out of there.
And then when you add to
that using coordination
to move cars and people close to
each other when they need them,
and then apart when
they don't, you
can sure get a lot of cars,
peoples, miles, seats,
without having to necessarily
multiply the number of tons
of steel by the number of people
to get the number of cars.
JOHN SCALZI: It's the effective
use of the cars as opposed
to the sheer number of cars.
CORY DOCTOROW:
Right, I mean, it's
better than the mere
despotic dominion over a car
that, after all, you then
have to take care of,
and find a place to put, and
all the rest of it, which
is inevitably the third best
car, or the fifth best car,
as opposed to the very
best car for your needs,
because you can't afford that.
The interesting move
of science fiction,
one of the best moves
is to take a
technological phenomenon
and see if it can be extracted
from its social and economic
context, and whether
it still works.
This is steampunk,
like what does it
mean if you could have the
machines with the factory?
Mad scientists could
do productivity
that are characteristic
of an assembly line,
but they can do it all
alone in their labs.
To imagine something
like fleet vehicles
without market
capitalism, without even
communal ownership,
that we're just
a kind of epic phenomenon
of cooperative work
without any
formalized structures,
that's a really provocative
thought experiment,
to imagine what
kind of arrangements
we'd get out of that.
JOHN SCALZI: I wish I had
a car, and a car drives up,
and you go into your car, and
then you say, goodbye car.
Thanks for driving me.
CORY DOCTOROW: Right, and if
it turns out there are no cars,
then some other thing
that you might want to do
is brought to your attention
that doesn't require a car.
There's a whole group of
people in "Walkaway" that
are the remnants of an
investment bubble in zeppelins.
And they, just
like 20 years ago,
we had this
investment bubble that
used pension funds
to teach humanities
majors how to write
JavaScript, this bubble turns
a whole ton of disaffected
post-millennials
into airship
builders and pilots,
but doesn't actually produce
a functional airship economy.
And so a bunch of them just
start building airships.
But they are
non-propelled airships.
They have minimal impellers.
And so they just go where
the winds are blowing.
But because they were all part
of this global phenomenon,
they kind of know
somewhere wherever
the winds might blow them.
And so it's a kind
of movable party.
You sort of check to see
who's on the next airship
through town, and
whether you know them.
And when you get
on the airship, you
check to see whether the next
town that the wind is blowing
you to is a place where
there might be someone
you want to hang out with.
And the automation
marries the two.
JOHN SCALZI: Fascinating.
Now, do you think
there are antecedents?
I mean not antecedents
in the human experience,
but antecedents to what you're
doing in science fiction?
I mean, one of the
things that I kind of see
"Walkaway" being is almost
like the seed culture
for in Banks' culture series.
CORY DOCTOROW: Yeah, sure.
Yeah, I think Banks
definitely was
writing about what a
post-scarcity world would
look like.
But if there's a
difference in our angle,
he's got this fait accompli.
And I'm thinking about
the transitional state,
which is a really interesting
moment to think about it.
And his emphasis is
really on manufacture
as opposed to coordination.
So his magical
technology is the,
to date still
rather fanciful idea
that matter can be conjured.
Organized matter
can be conjured up
out of code, which
notwithstanding
a few 3-D printers
around the margin
is not a thing that we do very
reliably at mass scale yet.
But for me, it doesn't
really matter if you've
got 3-D printers in Walkaway.
Walkaway works pretty good
even if all you've got
is just people who
are assembling stuff.
Because they're still able
to do process improvement.
They're still able to
feedback to one another.
They're still using
software and networks
to take whatever it is
they can make and make it
better on demand, continuously,
all around the world.
So it's hardware that acts
like a software object.
JOHN SCALZI: So basically
one of the things
that we talked about earlier
is like the triangle, you said.
You have process.
Tell me, remind me.
CORY DOCTOROW: Yeah, so the
triangle of post-scarcity,
up here you have what we want.
So Keynes wrote
this essay in 1930
about how his grandchildren
would struggle
to fill their lives after
the 15-hour work week was
introduced, because
there would be no reason
to work beyond that because
we could fill all our material
wants.
And the resolution to
Keynes's paradox today
is that Keynes
dramatically underestimated
how much people would want--
that people's
desires were elastic,
and responsive to
new material goods.
Or a cynic might
say that people are
amenable to marketing
messages, and want things
that they don't really want.
They can be convinced
in the moment
that they want something that
actually and objectively,
they don't want.
But whatever your explanation
is, that's up in this corner.
Down here, you have you
have the production.
But over here, you
have the ability
to coordinate what we want
with what we can make.
And the thing that allows
the Port of Guangzhou
to fire a shipping
container full of Happy Meal
toys at the Port of Los Angeles,
one a second, 365 days a year,
like a rail gun
firing tchotchkes,
is that's coordination.
These long supply chains
are all built up out
of coordination technology.
It's a marvel to behold.
And it's such an everyday marvel
that we don't even notice it.
And we think about 3-D
printers as being miraculous.
What's really miraculous
is that McDonald's can
sell you a burger with the
beef of 1,000 cows in it,
that we can do these
incredible, complex, seemingly
fragile supply chains that
nevertheless are really
robust against even
the burgeoning climate
problems of long-distance
shipping, and so on.
JOHN SCALZI: Sure.
And the reason I bring
that up is because you when
you were talking
about the triangle,
"Walkaway" is over
here, where you're
talking about coordination.
And someone like
Banks is over here.
Who's up at the top, then?
CORY DOCTOROW: Well,
that's the Huxley, that's
changing what we want, or
Marie Kondo, the cottage
industry of convincing you
that all you really want
is a smooth river rock that
reminds you of your mother,
as [INAUDIBLE] said.
It's the project
of Zen Buddhism,
the minimalist project.
The biggest enemy of
minimalism is precarity.
One of the major reasons
that people hold on to stuff
is because they're worried
that their circumstances might
change, and they might not be
able to afford to get it again,
even if they don't need it now.
That's why people
save their clothes
from before they lost
weight, or gained
weight, or whatever, because
they know that it would
cost them more to
replace it in the future
than they might have.
And so it's worth
the opportunity cost
of leaving it in their closet.
JOHN SCALZI: Well, no,
it's the whole idea
that everybody had a grandmother
or great-grandmother who
lived through the Depression,
who had a big ball of string.
And that big ball-- what
are you going to use
the big ball of string for?
You never know what you
might be able to use
that big ball of string for.
CORY DOCTOROW: I have
a homecoming ritual,
which is throwing out
all the non-working pens
in my parents' kitchen
whenever I visit Toronto.
JOHN SCALZI: Because
they do pile up.
CORY DOCTOROW:
Oh, yeah, they do.
And it's Gresham's
Law, the bad pens
drive out the good,
because the good pens
are the ones you take with
you in your bag and lose.
And the bad pens are the
ones that stay behind.
It's just broken pencils and--
JOHN SCALZI: You know that
in this bag right now,
I have got, like, six
working pens that I've
stolen from bookstores that
I've been on tour with.
I'm going to--
CORY DOCTOROW: Good
drives out the bad.
JOHN SCALZI: Right, because
then, they'll be like,
oh, we don't have any good pens.
I'm, like, I have one.
It's like, cool.
CORY DOCTOROW: So John,
you are incredibly
generous being at
the end of your tour,
with putting the
emphasis on my book here.
But I really want to talk more
about "Collapsing Empire,"
because it's a fascinating
and cracking read.
And you say that you're
a cheerful, quippy guy,
and so people mistake
you for an optimist
even though you
write about bastards.
But what I'm interested in is
why the interest in bastards?
Are they just fun to write?
JOHN SCALZI: They
are fun to write.
I mean, bastards are great fun.
You don't want
them in your life.
And in this particular
book, I have a character
who I love, who is one
of my favorite characters
that I've ever written.
And her name is Kiva Lagos.
And she is amazing
to read, and she's
amazing to watch in action.
And you know that if
she were your friend
and she was calling you,
you'd would be like, [SIGHS]
do I want to answer the phone?
Do I want to answer the
phone, because whatever's
going to happen, it's
going to be a thing,
and then I've got
to deal with it.
And I don't want to
deal with it right now.
I don't have time for this.
And you put it down.
And immediately afterwards,
there's a text that says,
"I know you're there.
Pick up the phone, you bastard."
CORY DOCTOROW: But
with more swearing.
JOHN SCALZI: With
much more swearing.
CORY DOCTOROW: She
is an epic swearer.
JOHN SCALZI: She
And last night, we were on tour.
And he's, like, you
don't swear very much.
Where does that come from?
And I just stared at him.
Because I am-- you don't know.
CORY DOCTOROW: I
never hear you swear.
JOHN SCALZI: You never--
CORY DOCTOROW: I
must only catch you
in moments of
great cheerfulness.
JOHN SCALZI: Of being very
well-behaved, it must be.
But in fact, I am
an epic swearer.
And I come from a grand
line of epic swearers.
And if you get us all together,
about 60% of our discourse
is swearing in one
way or another.
But she's a great character.
But she's also a
bit of a bastard.
She's our bastard,
so we like her.
But you still have
to deal with what
does that mean in terms
of character and story.
And the other thing is,
as we were talking about,
how our books, even though
they were completely unrelated
in the writing are
strangely complementary.
He is looking at the world
of a kind of a post-collapse
and the middle class and
lower classes dealing
with that, whereas in
"The Collapsing Empire,"
it is all focused on the
people who are up at the top.
CORY DOCTOROW: The
literal aristocracy.
JOHN SCALZI: The
literal aristocracy,
and their motivations are, in
some ways, very, very, very
different, because they
are the main beneficiaries
of this entire
interdependent system.
The whole point of
this system-- it
was built so that the 1%, or
actually, the 1/10 of the 1/10
of the 1%, would
benefit, basically,
from every exchange and every
transaction that would ever
happen in trade through space.
And so when they have evidence
that it's very likely to fail--
some of it's debatable evidence,
but it is very strong evidence,
nonetheless--
they kind of break up
into three general areas.
There's going to be
the people who say,
get everybody on the boat.
We're going to see how
many people we can save.
There are going to be
other people who are,
there's not enough room
in the boat for everybody.
Kick, kick, kick.
Just make sure my
family is on the boat.
And then there
are the people who
are, like, I don't know
whether or not things
are coming to an end or not.
All I know is I need
to own that boat,
because they're going to be
the person who is in control.
So their motivations
are actually
materially different
than hoi polloi
trying to get through
their day or trying
to adjust to this world.
Their focus is going
to be on preservation,
whether it's preservation on a
large scale with as many people
as possible, preservation
on a small scale with fewer
people, or preservation
of wealth and capital,
or whatever.
And because of
that, in many ways,
the impulses that
can be valorized
in those particular
situations seem
to be the ones that
also include bastardy.
CORY DOCTOROW: Right,
I mean, it's so--
I love the cynicism of
the political system,
where there's this hub that--
it's called Hub, right?
JOHN SCALZI: It's called Hub.
CORY DOCTOROW: That all of
the lay lines converge on,
and the power-brokers
have granted monopolies
on different technologies to
different spokes, the termini
of different spokes
of the Hub, such
that no one world
is self-sufficient.
And therefore, goods always
have to transit Hub to get to--
keep each of the
colonies running.
And if the Hub ever
breaks down, civilization
collapses across space.
So first of all, this is
a lovely bit of cynicism.
But what I found
really great was,
there's this kind of latent
thing, which I didn't even
realize until the book was over,
because as they're scrambling
to make plans, even the
best of them is not saying,
wait a second, how do we create
resilient independent colonies
before the hyperspace
loopholes disappear?
Because they're
going to be literally
unreachable for the
next million years,
and they can't make
their own food.
JOHN SCALZI: Right.
CORY DOCTOROW: And
no one's, like, how
do we make sure that that
distant world has food?
I love that.
We're getting a time
signal, here, for Q and A.
JOHN SCALZI: Yeah, so
what that means is,
very briefly, there is,
in fact, one character who
is leaning in that direction.
And the next book, I
believe, is actually
going to be about how
she tries to solve
that particular problem.
CORY DOCTOROW: I
kind of wondered.
Yeah, I kind of wondered.
JOHN SCALZI: It ends
on a cliffhanger,
which enraged a lot of
people, who were, like, what?
There's got to be more.
And I'm like, look,
it's a whole universe.
It needs a couple of books.
So that--
CORY DOCTOROW: My book has
a surprise ending, too.
The last 40% is just the same
word over and over again.
Don't tell anyone.
It's a spoiler.
JOHN SCALZI: But the
punctuation and the spacing--
CORY DOCTOROW: Is
very different.
JOHN SCALZI: It's
very, very different.
CORY DOCTOROW: It's,
yeah, steganography.
JOHN SCALZI: So we're going
to go into questions now,
and we actually have a thing
that we like to do, where--
Cory suggested it.
I agree with it--
that one question
comes from someone
who identifies as female.
CORY DOCTOROW: Or not binary.
JOHN SCALZI: The next one comes
from someone who identifies
as male and non binary.
And why do we do that, Cory?
CORY DOCTOROW: We do that
because otherwise, it's
a sausage fest.
Sorry, guys.
JOHN SCALZI: That is correct.
So we'll start with--
CORY DOCTOROW: Are any
people who identify
as female or non-binary who'd
like to ask the first question?
And there's a mic runner
who will come over
for the benefit of
the live stream.
JOHN SCALZI: Right, so
anyone raise your hands.
Otherwise, we'll move on.
There we go.
In back, in purple.
AUDIENCE: I'm not going
to ask the same question.
CORY DOCTOROW: I recognize
you from our event last night
in Santa Cruz.
Nice to see you again.
AUDIENCE: So is the
retention of wealth immoral?
JOHN SCALZI: Is the
No, I don't think the
retention of wealth
is inherently immoral.
I think there becomes
a point where,
if your retention
of wealth leads
to the overall reduction of
well-being of other people
I personally think
that's immoral,
because my moral system says,
do as well for everybody
as much as you can, in a very,
very general sort of way.
And so when the
concentration of wealth
means, for example,
that we valorize
the accumulation of wealth over,
say, the well-being of people
in realms of health, or
education, or housing,
or any of those sorts of
things, and it eventually
becomes that you really
create such a huge disparity
between the uppermost one-tenth
of one-tenth of one-tenth of 1%
and literally everybody
else in the world, yes, then
it becomes immoral.
But in the sense of--
in a very real sense, wealth
is an abstract concept
that we all agree to go along.
And so to some
extent, we all agree
to that particular delusion.
The problem, the
fall down, is when
that all-agreed-upon delusion
means that the majority suffer.
CORY DOCTOROW: Yeah, I
would take a more Piketty
version of this, where Piketty
basically says, why do we
tolerate imbalances in wealth?
Why do we not go and take?
If we want and someone else
has, why do we not go and take?
And why do we erect systems just
to establish stable property
relationships?
And his answer is that because
when we allocate wealth--
when people can have
wealth as a result of being
good allocators of wealth, when
being a good locator of wealth
gets you more wealth, so
when you allocate wealth
in a way that is beneficial
to the world, you get richer,
then you get more
wealth to allocate.
And the problem is that
intergenerational wealth
transfer doesn't create
efficient capital allocations.
And his example is to compare
Liliane Bettencourt, who's
the heiress of the L'Oreal
fortune, who has literally
never worked a day of her
life, and Bill Gates, who
founded the most successful
company in the history
of the world in his lifetime.
And Liliane Bettencourt
and Bill Gates,
starting from the same
place at the same time,
Liliane Bettencourt's fortune
grew more than Bill Gates' did,
even though she didn't
even allocate capital.
She just gave capital to
other people to allocate.
And then Bill Gates,
after he retired,
made more money still
in total than he
had while running the
largest company in the world.
So Bill Gates,
doing nothing apart
from being a financial
plumber, as opposed
to doing the non-commodity
thing of starting a business
that capital can
flow into, Bill Gates
doesn't make as much money.
And so there's this
kind of utilitarian,
but market-oriented reason
to do redistribution,
to care about intergenerational
wealth transfer.
But there's a simpler kind
of left-right version.
So there's a wonderful
left-wing fantasy
writer named Steven Brust.
He's a no-fooling
Trotskyist fantasy writer.
JOHN SCALZI: Yes, he is.
CORY DOCTOROW: And you can
tell he's a Marxist fantasy
writer, because he has the
right ratio of vassals to lords.
Normal fantasy writers
have way too few vassals.
But I was having drinks
with him once, and I said,
I don't even know what left
and right mean anymore.
And he said, it means
exactly the same thing
it's meant since the
French Revolution.
You ask, what is more
important, a property right
or a human right?
And if the person
you're asking says
property rights
are a human right,
they're on the political right.
And that is the question that
divides the two philosophies.
And so once you come
to the conclusion
that it's not a human
right, that it's merely
like a utilitarian thing,
then yes, of course,
there's real problems with
intergenerational wealth
transfer.
JOHN SCALZI: And the other
thing about it, and particularly
in the United States, is people
have a tendency in the United
States to believe that there
are two types of people.
There are the millionaires,
and the people who
are not the millionaires yet.
CORY DOCTOROW: Temporary
embarrassed millionaires,
as Steinbeck called them.
JOHN SCALZI: Right, exactly.
And if that is your
fundamental view of the world,
then ultimately, the question of
wealth accretion does, I think,
tend towards immorality.
So next question.
AUDIENCE: So hi.
And I hate to say this,
because I know you
make your living doing this.
But would you-- what do
you think about the fact
that, to be successful
in a post-scarcity world,
you have to completely ignore
all intellectual property law?
And I would argue that open
source is successful because it
found a way to do just that.
CORY DOCTOROW: Yeah,
Cory, so I think
you've got it wrong about
free and open source software.
I actually think-- so
I think you're right,
that the Free Software
movement's origins are
in opposition to the idea
of copyright and patent,
actually, against intellectual
monopoly more widely.
But it's a brilliant hack,
because what Stallman
did with the GPL was he created
a regime where the more you
strengthen copyright, the
more enforceable his license
that abjured copyright became.
And the weaker you
made copyright,
the less his license was
needed to accomplish its goals.
And so he created a
heads I win, tails
you lose situation
in the license.
I think that the idea of
exclusive rights over one's
intellectual
creations has always
been a battleground between
the utilitarian considerations,
self-deception, and emotional
feelings, animal sentiments.
So we have this
Lockean intuition
that when we infuse something
with our labor, it's ours.
And that leads to
the self-delusion
that when we infused
it with our labor,
we did not take anything from
anyone else that was theirs.
So when Edgar Allan Poe
invents the detective story,
he's just making plumbing.
When I write a
detective story, I'm
making something
special and unique to me
that no one can take without
doing me some irreparable harm.
And then from a utilitarian
perspective, we ask ourselves,
would the world
be a better place
if you could only
write detective stories
if Edgar Allan Poe's
estate said you could?
And it seems pretty clear that
there are, like, detectives.
Poe is-- I named my
daughter after Poe.
I'm not a--
I will brief for Poe.
But Poe had eccentric ideas.
And if we said to Poe, "You are
the arbiter of all detective
stories because of "Murders
in the Rue morgue,"
we would be a
poorer world for it.
And so I am a believer
in evidence-led copyright
and patent, where if we can
show that at the margin,
you produce more creativity,
more of whatever the underlying
purpose is by enacting some
temporary monopoly as specified
in the Constitution for the
promotion of the useful arts
and sciences, then let us do so.
But if the only
thing we're doing
is pandering to the
self-deception and the animal
sentiment, then I think
we do so at the cost
of our intellectual enrichment.
JOHN SCALZI: And also
there's the issue
of, it is the individual
versus the society thing, where
the individual creates
something that is basically
Hegelian in nature, because
we don't just pop things out
of the air.
The information exists
before that is your thesis.
You add something new to it.
That's your antithesis.
You get something out of it.
That's synthesis.
That synthesis is your creation.
Should you benefit from it?
Sure, because you
have done something
that no one else
has done before.
But you also didn't do it
independent of the rest
of the community
in which you live.
We do grant, as they say,
exclusive right to profit
from it for a certain
amount of time.
But what's really
important about that
is that it is the
individual that
has the right to profit from
it, and so on, and so forth.
So when you have-- and the
great thing about individuals
is that they die in
this particular setup,
because eventually, everything
about what the individual does
stops being of importance
to that individual,
because they're dead.
And then it becomes of the
use to the society in general,
unless they previously licensed
it, or do whatever else
to let it happen.
When you have a situation
where, for example,
the individual dies,
and then their children
and grandchildren, and
so on and so forth,
then become rent seekers on that
particular piece of property,
then to go back to the question,
is wealth immoral, then
you start having a real
question of the morality of it
relative to the benefit
of the society in general.
My personal feeling
about stuff like this,
and I think it may be
slightly different from yours,
is, I'm a big fan of
copyright for individuals
being life plus 20, or 75
years, whichever is longer
in the case of the individual.
Because the 20 then allows
the person's spouse and family
to get some limited
benefit after that.
But after that, it goes
into the community,
because quite honestly,
my grandchildren
should go either
get their own jobs,
or walk away, one
of those two things.
For corporations, I think 75.
And then the problem is, that
you have folks like Disney.
As much as I admire
Disney in many other ways,
but the fact that every time
Steamboat Willie comes up
to being put in
the public domain,
they somehow magically get to
extend the life of copyright.
CORY DOCTOROW: Although they've
got only one year to do it now,
because we're starting--
we're coming up
against the limits of the
20-year renewal in 1998.
So we're pretty close to it.
JOHN SCALZI: Don't worry,
we live in Trump's America.
CORY DOCTOROW: I hear you, where
legislation passes with ease.
JOHN SCALZI: But so, as
far as that goes, I mean,
there is that thing
that at a certain point,
the individual ceases to exist.
The benefit that the individual
accrues from it goes away,
and it has to go
back to the society,
because the society needs that
Hegelian process to create
new and compelling stuff.
CORY DOCTOROW: I want to suggest
a gloss, a friendly amendment.
JOHN SCALZI: Please do.
CORY DOCTOROW: Which is
that in addition to this,
you need an expansive safety
valve for free expression
that doesn't allow the
author to enjoin people
from using their work
to criticize their work.
And so I think that we
worry too much about things
like open licenses, and
too little about things
like limitations to
copyright, like fair use.
Our pole star shouldn't be,
I can write "The Wind Done
Gone," which was a
retelling of "Gone
with the Wind" from
the perspective
of the enslaved people, if
Margaret Mitchell tells me
I can.
And therefore, what
we should do is
kind of work on Margaret
Mitchell's estate
to get her to let
us tell that story.
What we should be saying is,
Margaret Mitchell's estate--
and this is what the
Supreme Court affirmed--
Margaret Mitchell's estate
doesn't get to decide.
And so we don't have to--
and in that regard, the
duration of copyright
becomes a lot less important.
Because one of the greatest
problems of the copyright
term is that it is accompanied
by a very narrow view
of limitations to copyright.
And so we not only have
a very long-lived thing,
but a very wide thing.
JOHN SCALZI: Right.
Now, I accept this gloss and
endorse it wholeheartedly.
CORY DOCTOROW: How
we doing for time?
JOHN SCALZI: Timewise?
CORY DOCTOROW: Do we
have time for more?
JOHN SCALZI: OK,
so next question.
CORY DOCTOROW: From
someone who identifies as
female or non-binary, please.
Right here.
AUDIENCE: This one's
for Mr. Scalzi.
Really curious how you
came up with the ship
names for "Collapsing
Empire," because I
enjoyed them very much.
JOHN SCALZI: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JOHN SCALZI: Specifically
it's a sort of a sub rosa--
not really sub rosa-- it's a
kind of an explicit testimonial
to Iain M. Banks, whose Culture
series I absolutely love,
creates the idea of a huge,
galaxy-spanning civilization.
Now, he writes with a sort of
verve and complexity that I
don't.
And in the sense of even
just in the sentences.
I mean, we all have
complicated universes.
That's why you love us.
But just the fact
of his Culture,
and the way that
he's built that,
and that there's so much there,
and even so much more implied,
I absolutely love.
And he and I were
up for a Locus Award
together, when I
did "Redshirts."
And he had just passed,
or was about to pass away.
And I remember explicitly
saying to people,
I'm absolutely happy that I'm
a finalist for this award.
If you were planning to vote for
me, please vote for Iain Banks.
Because not only was
"The Hydrogen Sonata"
a wonderful book
in and of itself,
but just as a proxy for the
entire series, I was like,
this would be a great time
and place to honor him.
I won.
My wife gave my
acceptance speech,
in which I dedicated it to him.
Because again, I feel like
I won, but he should have,
so this is his.
And this is my way,
and in my creating
this galaxy-spanning
thing, to acknowledge
that Iain Banks is a master
of this particular form.
And so every time someone
sees that and goes,
huh, it's like Iain
Banks, it's almost
like spending a prayer wheel.
In my book, Iain
Banks is remembered.
And that actually
makes me happy.
CORY DOCTOROW: I sneak my
favorite William Gibson line
into-- oh, yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
I take my favorite
William Gibson line
into about three-quarters
of my books, which is,
"Don't let the little
fuckers generation gap you."
And it's in-- it appears
in half a dozen of them.
I wanted to ask about
that, because Earth
is 1,000 years gone.
Earth has lost to
this civilization.
But they're all cool,
old, Tin Pan Alley songs.
Do you have a
continuity in mind?
Is that going to emerge,
why Tin Pan Alley survives?
JOHN SCALZI: I think it's just
basically the classical music
of its time.
So they'll pull it off.
And I think it's also, there
may be some sort of thing
where you want-- your ship names
have to be distinctive enough
that they're not going to
repeat, but at the same time,
have to be easy enough to
remember that you can say them.
And song lyrics do a
really good job of that.
I think there's
that thing that--
you shouldn't do
this for passwords.
But a long time ago,
people were, like,
if you have a hard time
remembering a thing, just use--
CORY DOCTOROW: Initialisms.
JOHN SCALZI: Yeah, or a
line of lyrics from a song,
or something like that.
You shouldn't do
it, because once
you actually see the pattern,
then it gives it all away.
And even a machine
can figure that out.
But just the idea that you can
remember a sequence of words
better than you might
remember just a single word
is kind of interesting to me.
CORY DOCTOROW: There's a thing
called Zooko's Triangle, which
says that identifiers can
be human readable, unique,
or collision resistant.
I forget what the third one is.
Does anyone remember
what the third corner
of Zooko's triangle was?
But it is this problem.
When you have independent
people coming up with
identifiers without being
able to talk to each other,
that you have this
really hard problem.
And you can use hashes.
But like calling your
spaceship the 80-character hash
of something is--
it's not the kind of thing
that people write songs about.
JOHN SCALZI: And it
really is the difference
between having a
personalized license plate
and having a VIN number.
OK, one last question.
You had your hand up first.
I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: So John, I
was curious about--
you mentioned in your
book that society kind of
has this infrastructure
that they take for granted.
And there's also been
this loss of knowledge
as to why existing principles,
why it kind of existed.
And you mentioned that someone--
people draw the conclusion
that you may be referring,
or it's an allegory about oil.
But I actually think
of it as an allegory
for another modern-day
infrastructure
that we're a little bit famous
for working with, that people
potentially take for granted.
And I'm curious, especially
with one of the groups
that's currently tasked
with protecting it, also
recently publishing
rules to kind of erode
key parts of why it exists,
and why it's important.
And just this thought
that every death
is kind of its own destruction
of a library of Alexandria is--
you lose a family
member, maybe I
should have asked them
something before they left.
Or I lost a team member, and
now suddenly, for a code,
like I should have called
this function holding a lock,
and now I have race
condition kind of thing.
It's like this information,
it's not quite codified,
but it's important.
And because it wasn't
distilled, and because others
weren't educated about it,
it's kind of lost in time.
Do either of you
have thoughts on how
we can better kind
of codify and educate
others about these things?
JOHN SCALZI: OK,
you danced around
what it was that you were
actually trying to describe.
I thought at first you
were going towards Google
Books or something.
But what is--
CORY DOCTOROW: What
group are you--
JOHN SCALZI: What were you
referring to explicitly?
AUDIENCE: I was curious
about net neutrality.
CORY DOCTOROW: Oh,
net neutrality.
JOHN SCALZI: I'm going
to let Cory talk first.
CORY DOCTOROW: Well, look, the
network neutrality question,
on its face, should be
really easy to square up.
Even if you believe in markets
as the solution to everything,
and you think
regulation is a problem,
phone companies don't
exist without regulation.
Like arguing about
whether or not
phone companies should or
shouldn't be regulated,
it's like arguing
about whether or not
ice cream should be cold.
The going Galt fiber
network involves
going to every
basement in New York,
and paying the clearing
price of digging it up
to put a piece of
fiber in it, that
is like umpteen
trillion dollars,
and you will never,
ever recoup it.
So without some
regulatory intervention
that gives you these literally
priceless rights of way--
priceless because you would get
this deadlock where when you
got down the last two
basements that controlled
the closing of the
loop, those people
would just price it at
the entire expected return
minus $1.
And so there's no
viable way to build
a telecom without
state intervention
into property rights.
And so if you're going to take
the King's Shilling, if you're
going to put your
copper in our dirt
that we clear the
way for for you,
than you have an
obligation to operate
that copper in the
public interest.
And you are welcome
to run your network
any way you want if you're
going to pay all the clearing
costs associated with it.
But when you're going
to use our largesse,
when you're going to
take a giant subsidy,
that subsidy comes
with a quid pro quo.
And that quid pro
quo is you give me
the bits I ask for when I ask
for them as quickly as you can,
not trading me to another
prisoner for a pack
of cigarettes, going to one
company or another, and saying,
how much will you pay me to
get your bits to Mr. Doctorow
faster than the guys
down the road will?
And the fact that
you have people
who claim to be
market supporters who
are unable to understand
this tells you that--
I think it's Mencken's
Aphorism that it's
impossible to get someone
to understand something
when his paycheck depends on
him not understanding it--
that the arguments are
so crummy for allowing
network discrimination.
And Susan Crawford had a
great op-ed about it today.
I think that we are
almost at the point
where maybe network neutrality
will be very hard to take away,
because we are
almost at the point
where we have pretty good
networks for enough people that
taking that away will
cause them to rise up.
Because it's very hard
to get people exercised
about a thing they've never
had, that we're telling them
their future has been
stolen from them.
This is one of the
problems with DRM,
is that we say there are
all these devices that
should exist now but
don't, because it's
against the law to break DRM
even for a legal purpose.
And so you stick a
CD in your computer,
and it wakes up
some software that
came from the
manufacturer that says,
I see you're visiting us
from the 20th century.
Would you like to move
your music into the 21st?
And handily puts it
on your mobile device,
and lets you turn it into
a ring tone, alarm tone,
and everything else.
Stick a DVD in,
and all it will do
was what it could do in
1996, which is play it.
20 years, not one new
feature added to DVD.
And people don't notice.
They don't even
notice that there
is nothing that happens when
you put a DVD in apart from what
it did 20 years ago.
But if they could do
all the things with DVDs
that they can do with
CDs, and then we told them
they couldn't do
it anymore, there
would be blood in the streets.
And what Obama was very
canny about was creating
an unsustainable health care
system that nevertheless
insured 22 million uninsured
people, who would then,
when that system ran up against
the limits of the compromises
he had to make with the insurers
to get it through, would,
instead of saying,
all right, then,
I guess we'll go back
to the old bad ways,
would then plump
for single payer.
JOHN SCALZI: I
was wondering when
we would get to health care
on that, because that is--
[LAUGHTER]
--because boy, that is the
one that really does point
to what he is saying there.
I mean, the fact is
that, if all of a sudden,
I have to pay an extra $20 for
the tier that allows me to get
Netflix, which I already get
for free minus the Netflix
subscription cost,
or that it basically
goes into the cable
model, then people are
going to freak out about it.
Because they already have it.
That's their already
ground-level expectation.
Once you give people something,
and you give it sufficient time
to take root as that
is the expectation,
that is always going to be
part of that expectation.
And you do have basically
what are, I would say,
Randian acolytes going,
no, we should actually
do it this particular way,
and pare away everything
that doesn't allow
you to, or that
has anything to do with the
government doing anything
other than shooting
people, and saying,
oh, no, this is more efficient.
And of course, we can trust
other people to do that.
And it just doesn't work.
I mean, implicit in a lot
of the philosophies that
lead to something like
breaking net neutrality
or taking away the health
care that other people have
is the assumption that
the only things that exist
are you and the ground no
more than six feet under you.
And so everything else will just
sort of take care of itself.
And of course, it doesn't.
And that's the aspect, I
think, in both of our books.
Everything is interconnected.
Everything works together or
it doesn't, but there's always
going to be factors that
you have to deal with.
I, obviously, and
I think this is
a non-controversial
statement, think
that trying to reverse net
neutrality is purely stupid.
It doesn't benefit anyone but a
certain number of small people,
again, up at the top.
It is going to present real
issues for the vast majority
of people at the bottom.
And the potential
for the internet,
and the potentials for
these networks, which
is to have the potential to
raise up and then flatten out
things like access,
things like education,
things like communication,
goes away simply
for the benefit of three
or four or five companies
and the attendant CEOs and
executive class of those.
CORY DOCTOROW: And shareholders.
JOHN SCALZI: And bluntly--
and I'm sorry that
I'm going to use
a bad word here on the Google
streaming thing-- fuck that.
I'm not here for the top 10.
I'm speaking as someone
who's in the 1% myself.
I'm not here for those people.
I want the benefit
of this for everyone,
because I also have come down
from the very bottom of our US
society, and I know how
crappy and how awful it is,
and how trivial it is to
improve the lives of people
at the bottom through
things like access
to computers, to
things like networks,
to things like education.
And so every time you
have an administration
like this administration,
which is just full-scale,
let's sprint as
fast as we possibly
can towards oligarchy,
because to the rest of you,
then, yeah you get my back up.
So the current
head of the FCC can
go dunk his head in the toilet
and flush several times,
as far as I'm concerned.
We need net neutrality.
[APPLAUSE]
CORY DOCTOROW: Awesome.
Fight the power.
JOHN SCALZI: Exactly.
SPEAKER: Let's hear it
again for John and Cory.
That was awesome.
JOHN SCALZI: Thank you guys.
CORY DOCTOROW: Thank you all.
[APPLAUSE]